[Music]
that's northwest and a friend belting
out we don't talk about bruno as proud
mom kim kardashian captures their car
ride concerts
[Music]
north is joined by tracy romulus's
daughter ryan and these two give the
encounter hit their all
[Music]
and love for the disney musical is a
true family affair
with khloe kardashian sharing video of
daughter true and rob's daughter dream
also vibing to the viral track
let's go girls
[Music]
okay now are we done talking about bruno
no no no
yep these moments come after kim and
oldest son saint had their own sing
along
[Music]
of course kim and north have a tick tock
account dedicated to their music collabs
yes so that's what i was saying
[Music]
and these on the go karaoke jams come as
no surprise as kim joked to ellen
degeneres last year she's now a full-on
carpool mom and north you know i thought
she was going to grow out of this like i
want to be an only child phase
she hasn't morning drop off has to be
like a fun thing and luckily so many are
friends and cousins they all live in the
same neighborhood so i'm like the
carpool mom and i have to separate the
kids because she wants
her own music she wants her own vibe she
wants to sing with her friend it's so i
have to trade off it's always a thing
bribe
my brain
[Music]
[Music]
i'm